[Música]
en france 24 es hora de hablar de
deportes por eso me acompaña el luis
méndez luis cordial saludo y comenzamos
hablando de fútbol porque inicio la copa
de africana de naciones
así es de daniela un evento que se debió
haber realizado en el año 2021 pero que
se trasladó a la presente fecha debido a
la pandemia de kobe 19 ya en la primera
jornada presentó a los ganadores pero
más temprano nuestro enviado especial
federico fue barberena nos ofreció el
siguiente reporte escuche más la fiesta
fue completa para camerún en la apertura
de la copa africana de naciones después
de una ceremonia inaugural bella que
tuvo guiños a la cultura a la pasión por
el fútbol y a la biodiversidad del país
el equipo camerunés se supo revertir el
resultado y se impuso 2 a 1 a burkina
faso no fue una tarea fácil para los
leones indomables que comenzaron con
ímpetu pero se encontraron a un equipo
bien parado y que supo aprovechar su
primera ocasión clara fue mediante
gustavo sangaré quien
una jugada con tres envíos al área
aprovechó la mala salida de nana para
marcar el 1 a 0 sin demasiadas ideas
para la creación también encontró la
solución es a través del punto penal dos
infracciones la segunda antes del cierre
de la primera parte le permitieron a
vincent aboubakar anotar por duplicado y
de esa manera ratificar que cuando juega
con su selección levanta mucho su nivel
con eso le alcanzó a camerún que no
brilló pero pero superó el principal
escollo en este grupo
y ahora puede pensar en seguir mejorando
para el resto del torneo mientras que
para burkina faso no fue todo negativo
pero también tendrá que trabajar sobre
todo cuando le toca salir a buscar los
resultados algo que puede llegar a
ocurrirle en sus próximos encuentros en
otro duelo de la jornada acabó verde
venció a etiopía con marcador de un gol
por 0 en este grupo este martes será el
segundo día de acción en el torneo con
los encuentros entre senegal enfrentando
sin embargo en guinea enfrentará a
malawi marruecos enfrentará a ghana y
como ahora estará midiéndose a capón no
espero no puedo dejar de preguntarle por
el coach 19 porque fue uno de los temas
más de toda esta copa africana de
naciones que ha pasado con eso sobre
todo las últimas semanas como ya lo
habíamos adelantado por el aumento de
contagios en una nación donde tan sólo
un 5% cuenta con el esquema completo de
vacunación
pero para ello vamos a volver allá donde
para preguntarle a federico qué
barberena cómo se dio el control el
acceso a los fanáticos sabemos que hay
restricciones en cuanto a la capacidad
de los estadios para albergar este
torneo
los controles estuvieron reforzados en
el estadio o en vez de yaundé no solo en
los sanitarios sino también en materia
de seguridad muchos controles debieron
pasar a los fanáticos sobre todo para
demostrar que cumplían con los
requisitos de tener la vacunación contra
el cob y 19 y de presentar un test
negativo de la enfermedad la otra norma
que pareció cumplirse fue en la
reducción de la capacidad del estadio al
80 por ciento por eso no hubo un lleno
total pero quienes asistieron al estadio
igual se las ingeniaron con música con
baile y con diversos elementos para dar
un clima ensordecedor a este debut la
sensación entre el público fue de
satisfacción por la victoria y también
de orgullo por la organización de un
torneo que esperaron durante casi 50
años que pudieron llevar adelante
después de dos postergaciones y que para
ellos es un motivo de orgullo de esta
manera cameron en esta inauguración al
menos estuvo a la altura